the Pentagon says it successfully tested
a missile defense system that could
protect the United States from North
Korea the military first fired a target
missile yesterday from a remote island
in the Pacific then it launched an
interceptor missile from California to
destroy it and video shows the
interceptor launched the ability to
shoot down an intercontinental missile
comes just days after the latest North
Korean missile test David Martin is at
the Pentagon David good morning good
morning since North Korea has said it is
finishing work on an intercontinental
ballistic missile this was an important
demonstration that the US has the
capability at least under test
conditions to shoot down an incoming
ICBM the target a missile with the
trajectory and speed of an ICBM was
launched from the Kwajalein Atoll in the
Pacific minutes later an interceptor
missile blasted off from Vandenberg Air
Force Base in California maneuvering
into the path of the incoming ICBM
traveling at roughly four miles per
second according to the Pentagon's
missile defense agency the kill vehicle
intercepted and destroyed the target in
a direct collision 36 interceptors are
based in silos in California and Alaska
they go on alert every time the u.s.
expects another missile test by North
Korea but until now the system had never
been tested against a missile capable of
threatening the US homeland with a
nuclear warhead this test which costs
244 million dollars and was nearly three
years in the planning brings the overall
success rate to ten intercepts in 18
tries a modest record even though test
conditions allow time to move powerful
radars like this sea-based x-band radar
into position Tomasz Caraco is with the
Center for Strategic and International
Studies the most realistic test the only
true realistic test would be if North
Korea were to launch something at the
United States nobody wants that kind of
realism if it were the real thing with
little or no warning the US would have
to launch multiple interceptors against
an incoming missile so if one missed the
second or third might hit and so in that
sense you also kind of reduced
reduce the risk of any one particular
interceptor failing and you kind of
increase the effectiveness the Blakely
hood you're going to kill it it's hard
to think of the United States and an
arms race with an impoverished country
like North Korea but that is essentially
what's happening u.s. missile defense is
racing to keep a head of North Korean
nuclear missiles Gayle it is hard to
think of it in those terms thank you
very much David